colombia celebra hoy el día
internacional de la eliminación de la
violencia contra las mujeres por lo que
se han llevado a cabo distintas
manifestaciones a lo largo de todo el
país aquí en la capital bogotá las
mujeres se han reunido en el sur para
realizar una marcha que terminara en la
céntrica plaza bolívar con un concierto
y un velatón en honor a las víctimas de
feminicidios y es que más de 525 mujeres
han sido asesinadas en lo que va de año
en el país por ello las mujeres están
hoy aquí para reivindicar es el fin y el
cese de estas violencias que son
múltiples desde la violencia económica
recordemos que más del 16 por ciento de
las mujeres en colombia están en paro
hasta la violencia psicológica o
violencia sexual en el último año según
medicina legal ha habido más de 16.000
casos de abusos sexuales contra mujeres
en colombia también recordemos que ayer
se celebró el día el quinto aniversario
de los acuerdos de paz entre el estado
colombiano y la extinta guerrilla de las
farc desde la firma más de 178 lideresas
y activistas medioambientales han sido
asesinadas en el país por ello las
mujeres de los territorios han salido
también a las calles si es que están
reivindicando una violencia el cese de
la violencia contra las mujeres de las
zonas rurales contra las mujeres étnicas
o contra las afro es una violencia que
como vemos no se hace en colombia porque
se ha incrementado un 30% en lo que va
de año